the show was not renewed for a second
season what do you think would have
happened if that wasn't I probably would
have died I mean that's the god-honest
truth I I don't think had I not gotten
sober in that moment and really taking a
step back that I would be sober today
let's turn now to the bling ring that
gang of youths charged with breaking
into the homes of Hollywood's rich and
famous making off of some of the most
prized possession LAPD searched your
house
according to police the kids in the
bling ring would wait till the
celebrities were out of town and then
used maps on the Internet to case the
homes before they showed up to steal
this is Alexis Neiers calling in almost
ten years since pretty wild premiere and
alexis Hanes formerly Alexis Neiers was
a very different life now and she's in
studio to talk about it I'm very excited
to have you thanks for having me you
wrote a book recovering from reality my
journey back to wholeness yes I just
kind of felt like it was time it had
been nine years later since I got sober
I got sober when I was 19 years old and
really put behind the old lifestyle that
I had and had built this new big
beautiful life around me and it felt
like this is the time you do not hold
back at all no what I found in my kind
of later stages of my healing is that I
need to reclaim my story and my story is
one that's filled with a lot of
heartache and almost every form of
trauma possible and so I just said you
know I'd screw it I'm not gonna hold
back and I'm gonna tell my truth from my
early childhood sexual abuse my parents
divorce my drug issues and when they
began the physical violence that was
taking place the sexual assault that I
had that I incurred later on in my life
and then of course pretty wild in the
bling ring and my life now and how you
go from all of that trauma and all of
that
humiliation and embarrassment into
recovery I'm just here to show you that
like if I can do it anybody can do it if
I can publicly burn my life down and
have everybody ridicule me for it and
have a very you know public addiction
and go to jail multiple times and heal
then you can too
let's talk about the the addiction
because that kind of came out at least
for me as a fan of pretty wild that came
up down the line yeah that wasn't
something that we knew about so we're
you were on drugs during the show I was
yeah I been on drugs pretty much
consistently from around my middle
school years until I got sober when I
was 19
it began with just you know teenage
stuff smoking pot drinking warm beers
out of my friends fridges in the garage
and and going to parties but by the time
I was 15 I became addicted to oxycontin
and from there my addiction progressed
really quickly the funds that I was
getting from the show allowed me to
basically for my addiction to explode
and so by the time that I was 17 I was
using heroin every single day all day
long and that didn't stop until I got
sober after my second arrest when I was
19 have you rewatched the show at all I
have watched bits and pieces so the I
laughs like the meme of all memes of me
melting down to Nancy Joe is sent to me
almost on a daily basis on Instagram and
now I actually find it really funny and
I can laugh at those parts of myself
because it is kind of comical right I
mean it's sad and there was
heartbreaking
there's definitely stages of healing and
now I'm at the point where I can laugh
at myself and say okay this is
completely absurd yeah so I've watched
back bits and pieces there are still
episodes that I've never seen there
anything that you know about her I've
seen on the show where you're like oh
that I was fully I mean I was loaded
like from the second we started filming
until the second we stopped I mean when
you have a an addiction to opiates you
literally can't stop because you start
going through really painful
excruciating
painful withdrawal symptoms and so yeah
I I used in between every single
different you know location that we
filmed that I would sink into the
bathroom and and use and yeah escape as
much as I could at what point did you
realize I need to get home the first
time I went to jail so I ended up
accepting a plea deal and I spent a
summer in jail on a six-month sentence
and this is the Bling Ring yep and so I
could clearly see that opiates were a
big problem for me I went through
withdrawal in jail which is brutal and I
knew okay there's a problem here clearly
I cannot consume these substances like
this I'm destroying my life how did I
get here all of those things transpired
in jail and then when I got out I had
every intention of staying clean but we
know that the reality of that when you
don't have proper support is slim to
none within two weeks it was back off to
the races and my addiction actually got
worse even though I had less money and
less access I began shooting up
intravenously which is something that I
wasn't doing on a regular basis before
and I was panhandling for money and I
had nothing left all of these things
ended up becoming one of the biggest
blessings in my life though cuz I would
not be sitting here today had all of
that not transpired I wasn't say do you
look back at pretty while being a
blessing or a curse a blessing yeah a
blessing as industry's known for having
people in it that have a lot of
substance abuse issues and so that
trauma and that pressure is like
amplified when you're on TV right and
and so it drove me to a bottom fast and
so while nobody else is responsible for
all of that except for me it amplified
that and I'm just grateful that I was
given a second chance because that's
what ended up happening Judge Peter
Espinoza saved my life I ended up being
arrested for possession of heroin and
he saved me he sentenced me to treatment
instead of three to six years in prison
how long have you been sober now coming
up in December it'll be nine years off
of heroin and I did relapse on whippets
in treatment so I don't count my sober
date until March so but yeah almost nine
years resolution to you that's amazing
what would you say the biggest
misconception is about sobriety so many
people think their lives are over when I
get sober if that everything's gonna be
boring that they're not gonna have
friends that they're not gonna be the
same person that they were that
vivacious funny or whatever their alter
ego was when they were using that that's
gonna go away and I'm just here to say
that you can have a big beautiful
fulfilled life it's not easier by any
means it's actually I would argue harder
in a lot of ways but it is so worth it
and just as funny and silly you have
just as much energy as I did before I'm
a little bit more tired because I'm a
mom in your book you describe yourself
as a suburban housewife two little girls
a dog a cat and a husband mm-hmm did you
ever expect to get to this point no no I
didn't especially with my dating history
it was like I was always into the bad
boys who broke her heart and you know
and I was a mess myself and thought I
was so unlovable and then here comes
this amazing man who was Canadian didn't
really know about my past but when he
found out about it he loved it he was
like are you kidding like that's the
ultimate redemption story I love that
about you and so finding someone that I
felt like I could be authentically
myself with was huge and I'm so lucky
he's just the best partner I mean okay
I'm like anything about him but that's
great great he's amazing I mean two kids
later dashing about the husband they've
been married for seven years and we are
madly in love with each other how did
you guys meet we met in AAA I don't
advise it works for us but like not for
everybody yeah there was none of that
you complete me stuff we knew that we
need to be to complete individuals
entering into this couple ship together
when we got together and I think that
that's something that we work really
hard to support each other on so making
sure he knows what he needs to do for
his self-care and I know what I need for
mine and then of course parenting
together and having that family time and
all of that so yeah it's definitely a
juggling act yeah so how old are your
girls my youngest is three my oldest is
six okay what happens like I say a
decade from now when they discover yeah
pretty wild like have you thought about
how you would run I have you know we own
a drug-and-alcohol treatment center a
low house and my kids have seen
addiction and the way that it affects
people I mean they're growing up in a
community of people who are in recovery
they know what addiction is they know
that mommy and daddy don't consume
substances and honestly I don't think
it'll be like a huge deal we're really
open parents you know I I don't foresee
it being a huge issue yeah and if it is
I'll stick him in therapy let's talk
about the podcasts you did something
that I think a lot of pretty wild fans
were elated to see was the relationship
the reunion with the family which we
have not seen you guys on camera
together since the show really can we
talk about your relationships with them
where they stand today because Tess you
guys were thick as thieves in the show
like would not spend a minute apart and
then a couple years down the road I
think in an interview you said you guys
were not talking anymore where do you
guys stand today that's probably the
most challenging relationship out of all
of them one that I had to look at my
part in which was a from a codependent
standpoint and the way that I put so
much of me into this relationship and
just wasn't getting the same amount out
and I'm not you know you have to look at
your side of the road and then somebody
else's and you also have to accept and
meet people where they're at and it is a
challenge I like I feel a most like I
can feel like most of my body I love her
very much but sometimes you have to take
a step back and just say like this is
not serving me any
so you guys don't talk anymore we don't
talk as often yeah and I went to go
visit her I tried to see her in
Wisconsin she lives in Wisconsin now and
she has a beautiful family I'm so happy
for her like the fact that she made it
out to yes her because you guys were
yeah he's hand together yeah so I mean
that's a miracle and I'm so so happy for
her and I can't express that enough it's
just sometimes you have to realize that
these relationships dumping all my time
is not serving either of us anymore
is she still like a wake your sister do
you still consider that or yeah I'll
always consider her family and I'll
always love her very much
Gaby younger sister Gabby yeah my
relationship with Gabby also has highs
and lows I think that it is definitely
better and we have gone to therapy we
have just really we had two different
childhoods under the same roof which is
common in chaotic families everyone
plays their role right yeah and so she
was like the perfectionist never gonna
get in trouble you know and and I very
much so what's the wild child who's
gonna rebel and you know scream from the
rooftops that this is crazy and so yeah
we are doing great she got married a
little over a year ago I adore her
husband I'm so happy for them yeah I
mean it's crazy that little Gabby's 29 I
was gonna say my wife oh my gosh yeah
wow that's amazing
your mom mm-hmm how is she doing she is
doing well about two years into my
recovery she finally realized that she
had made a lot of mistakes as a parent
and she jumped into therapy and coaching
and now she actually helps other
families not go down the same path we
did and she developed a program called
families United for recovery
she has groups and Wesley in Malibu
every Wednesday night and is doing great
things I'm really proud of her I have to
imagine she got pretty scrutinized from
that show because I can eat like
kicks-off and they're like girls come
down take your adderall and then
everything kind of happened that
that I have to imagine she got a lot of
heat from that trail she definitely did
I mean I think we all did some more than
others yeah you know that was back in
the day we would like the soup and all
of those shows where all they did was
look at reality stars it was just so we
made for perfect reality TV yeah well
because they came at of I mean it wasn't
what the show was supposed to be
originally right wasn't it like a
different car yeah so the show took a
180 when I was arrested so it was
supposed to be just kind of like the
hippie crunchy version of the
Kardashians and then all of a sudden it
made a 180 when I was arrested on the
second day of filming Wow wasn't it
supposed to be called something else it
was supposed to be called yeah home
school to the Arlington so it's just
funny because both test and I were out
of school at that point but whatever it
worked it's it's interesting watching
these shows back kind of knowing how the
reality world works a little more like
there's times like I I just did a
rewatch with the show and there was
times where I was like I don't think
she's crying because she's sad at this
situation I think she's crying pissed at
production yeah I mean is there anything
looking back at that show you stick that
sticks out to you was like a storyline
that was everyone thought that I was
like crying over Xavier but really I was
crying because TMZ posted that I was in
Mexico and I guess I wasn't supposed to
be but I didn't know that and I went
there with production been getting that
everything was gonna be fine
and Here I am finally like living a
little like taking a little bit of a
breather after being hounded every
single day here in LA and then it was
like two days later oh you got to go
back and then the Nancy Joe call that
wasn't the initial reaction I recorded
that voicemail so many times and the
final moment where I blew up like that
was after many takes of doing that that
recording this was back in the day where
if it didn't read your voicemail or
register your voicemail it would say
we're sorry but you know please rerecord
after finished press one and so I just
kept rear according and recording and
that's the famous line to my mom every
time you yeah I have to rerecord it
because she would yell in the background
and then it wouldn't pick
the audio on the voicemail and I would
have to do it over and over again
Nancy Joe this is Alexis Neiers calling
$29 so was that more you wanting to
rerecord the voicemail cuz you didn't
like it or was it production being like
we need it again no no no it was it was
literally I was like I'm just trying to
get through this scene and can you like
shut up and so I can finish like I just
want to be done I just was humiliated I
mean people didn't get to see the behind
the scenes they saw little clips of me
meeting with Nancy Joe and of course the
clips that the producers liked which is
me talking about how I wanted to be like
Angelina Jolie or whatever I was or like
it was like it was all like the bad
parts but I had sat with Nancy for hours
and hours talking to her she was someone
that I really trusted and she promised
me you know we made a conscious choice
that we weren't gonna do any media
except for her so this is kind of gonna
be like my one shot at not that I had
many redeeming qualities back then
because I did it but I was just like
child I was 18 18 yeah just turned 18
when we started filming the show so you
know I really I trusted her and so here
comes the article and I'm so excited to
read it she had said she wasn't gonna
talk to any other members of the
flavouring all of the stuff and then I
read it and then I was like oh my god
not only is this not what I expected but
she's fabricating what I'm wearing into
court and all of that and and so it was
pretty devastating have you ever talked
to her yeah I am voicemail yeah
I recently reached out and I was like
Nancy like come on the podcast let's
hash it out let's talk about the way
that women are portrayed in media Wow
I mean she has not changed in ten years
and that's all I'm gonna say about that
some things she was just straight up
making up like things that she thinks
our facts are not facts and it's Court
record and very public and I was kind of
taken by surprise you one fact wearing
maybe she choose yeah well that made her
a brown baby back when I got she blocked
me on Twitter because II went and pulled
the footage and proved that I was
wearing the shoes and then she
that was not that wasn't Pleasant oh wow
so the show was not renewed for a second
season I mean at that point Tessa's
addiction was through the roof I was in
rehab there wasn't much to renew what do
you think would have happened if that
was right I probably would have died
yeah I mean that's the god-honest truth
i I don't think had I not gotten sober
in that moment and really taking a step
back that I would be sobered today was
there a point during all of that where
you were like I'm gonna die if I don't
yeah those last couple of months many
times and you know Tess had an overdose
that I was present for and resuscitated
her and oh my gosh yeah her even that
happened it was 18 you actively walked
away from the limelight was that a
difficult decision where you ever like
tempted to come back over the last nine
years yes when I got sober I was about
to file for bankruptcy like my whole
life was in shatters and I I can totally
understand like the you know it's quick
and easy money I'll just go on any
reality show and make 50 grand and then
you know survive for a little bit longer
and so that was very tempting and I'm
very grateful that for whatever reason
my brain just kept saying stop not worth
it would you ever do a reality show now
or like maybe in the future because
you're in a totally different place yeah
I considered it I mean it would
definitely depend on the show yeah I
mean has that have like offers come your
way that you a number of offers at my
way and so far it just doesn't feel
right congratulations on everything I
mean it's like really awesome to talk to
you and yeah I just can't wait for
people to know more about your story and
yeah
[Music]